does this scream sound familiar that's
because it's used in over 100 films it's
a movie trope called the Wilhelm scream
the Wilhelm scream is maybe the most
famous sound effect in Hollywood it is
used when characters are shot or fall
off high places in action films the
scream made its first appearance in a
1951 film called distant drums and
there's a moment in the film where a
character is dragged into the swamp and
they wanted a particularly
blood-curdling scream now this was just
one of many different screams in the
film to make a film you need a sound
effects library a collection of sound
effects and you're going to use them in
different parts of the film maybe in one
part of your action film you need a
two-second scream but in another part of
your film you might need a one and a
half second blood-curdling screams
producers had cast members record a
variety of different screams but there
was one man scream a particular that
stood out among the rest it's usually
credited now to Sheb Wooley who was a
kind of a western style character actor
and a novelty singer who appears in
distant drums but its first appearance
in 1951 wasn't the screams shining
moment that happened when it was used
again in the 1953 film the charge at
Feather River a character named private
Wilhelm was shot in the leg with an
arrow
and that's how it got named the Wilhelm
scream since then the sound has been
used in more than 100 films
[Music]
why well for one it's cheaper and easier
to reuse pre-existing sound effects you
have to give credit to Ben Burtt the
wonderful sound designer who's been
working on the biggest films in
Hollywood since the 1970s close
associate of George Lucas he's the one
who really discovered the Wilhelm scream
and researched out its origins Burtt
used the scream in a memorable moment in
Star Wars Luke Skywalker fires at a
stormtrooper this cream actually appears
in all of the original Star Wars films
and then it became an in-joke the screen
then spread to many other famous films
Steven Spielberg picked up on it used it
many many of his films and then it just
went crazy of course Peter Jackson uses
it in the Lord of the Rings even shows
up in Toy Story and Reservoir Dogs the
sound is now famous among film buffs I
think you can go on YouTube and see
compilations of dozens of Willhelm
screams I mean it has its own Wikipedia
entry and so for people that love movies
this is part of their enjoyment of it is
finding this little insider detail
[Music]